[MUSIC PLAYING]
PAUL REGINATO:
I'm Paul Reginato,
a biological engineer at the
McGovern Institute at MIT.
I make maps of cells.
Think of a cell as a tiny
city with all sorts of objects
interacting in organized ways.
The way most scientists
study cells gives us
a list of the
objects within them.
That helps, but we need
to know where things are
in addition to what things are.
That's where I come in.
I make maps of a cell's
DNA, or its genome.
Each cell contains
six feet of DNA.
And all this DNA has to fit
into a tiny space only 10
microns wide.
Further, it needs
to be organized
into specific shapes
in different cells
to function properly.
We developed a
technology that lets
us read the letters of the
genome right inside the cell.
This allows us to create a map.
By showing us how DNA is
organized inside cells,
our mapping technology will
be useful for understanding
how neurons process information
and much, much more.
[MUSIC PLAYING]